[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Good afternoon, everybody.
I'm Jane Kamensky.
I'm the Pforzheimer
Foundation director
of the Schlesinger
Library, which
is a very lucky thing to be.
And my job this
afternoon is to be
the introducer of
the introducer,
to welcome you on
behalf of Schlesinger,
one of Radcliffe's core
program and the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Studies.
Schlesinger Library
arranged this program,
which Nancy Weiss Malkiel
was kind enough to assent to.
And it follows the direction of
all of our public programming,
which raises crucial
questions about women gender,
sexuality in the history and
structure of American society,
thus furthering one of Radcliffe
Institute's core missions
and exposing the field-defining
and field-defying work
that people do in Schlesinger
Library collections.
You'll find that Nancy Weiss
Malkiel's towering book, Keep
the Damned Women Out,
does all of those things.
Often the work that comes
out of the sorts of research
we feature is unfinished work.
And I think that's
represented by the fact
that today's talk
is called Still
Struggling Toward Coeducation.
In a weird quirk
of timing, we're
up against the Harvard
FAS faculty meeting, which
is right now discussing the
fate of single-gender, typically
all-male social organizations
adjacent to and imbricated
with our campus in 2017.
The next major Schlesinger
Library-sponsored program--
there is a beautifully
designed postcard
at the back of the room.
It's called Hidden
in Plain Sight:
Family Secrets and American
History, in mid-November,
November 17.
And I also want to
call your attention
to one of Radcliffe's
many events
that may be of particular
interest to today's audience.
On Thursday, November 2
at 4:15, the Institute
will welcome the distinguished
historian of American politics
and social movements, Michael
Kazin, to give a lecture
entitled Does the
Left Have a Future?,
a question to which we
badly need an answer--
an affirmative answer.
The order of business this
evening will be as follows.
Radcliffe's dean,
Lizabeth Cohen,
will properly
introduce our speaker.
Then professor Malkiel
will give her talk,
followed by a question
and answer period.
And then after that,
you're all invited
to join her and continue the
conversation in a reception
right here in the back of the
room at the Knafel Center.
And with that, I will turn
the mic over to Liz Cohen.
But one thing first.
Many of you will know from
your email this afternoon,
but some of you will not,
that President Faust announced
earlier today Dean
Cohen's decision
to step down from the Radcliffe
deanship at the end of June.
Programs like this
one are the tip
of the iceberg of
what Liz has built
at Radcliffe as an
institute of advanced study
that honors its origins
in Radcliffe College,
but also transcends
them, and that
brings the fruits
of advanced study
to a broad public in
occasions like this one.
We will have many chances to
recognize Liz's work as dean
publicly in the months ahead.
But I think this is the first,
so I ask that we do so now.
Thanks, Liz.
[APPLAUSE]
- Good afternoon.
Thank you all.
Good afternoon.
And thank you Jane for
that lovely message.
You can imagine this is
a bittersweet moment,
the first of many.
I'm delighted to have you
all here at the Radcliffe
Institute.
And I'm especially glad to have
the pleasure of introducing
an old friend and
a fellow historian,
Nancy Weiss Malkiel, not
least because the work
that she is here to discuss
has special relevance
to Radcliffe and to Harvard.
Today, Radcliffe is an Institute
for Advanced Study, committed
to rigorous inquiry across
disciplinary boundaries
and to sharing that work through
extensive public programming.
But we haven't always been an
Institute for Advanced Study.
As I'm sure that many
if not all of you know,
today's Radcliffe Institute
began as Radcliffe College.
We honor this legacy regularly.
And that history is
indelibly imprinted on us,
despite the enormous
change in our mission.
For one thing, from its earliest
days as the so-called Harvard
Annex, established
in 1879, Radcliffe
was dedicated to providing
a Harvard-quality education
to those who would not
otherwise have had access
to it, namely women.
Later, when Elizabeth
Cary Agassiz
founded Radcliffe
College in 1894,
women were not only
awarded bachelor's degrees
from Radcliffe,
but PhDs as well.
When many graduate schools
additionally denied entry
to African-Americans,
Radcliffe opened its doors
to Eva Beatrice Dykes, who was
a graduate student in 1921,
became the first
African-American woman
in the country to complete
the requirement to earn a PhD.
In short, when Harvard
kept people out,
Radcliffe welcomed them in.
Radcliffe continues
this tradition
of promoting diversity and
inclusion in a number of ways.
Since the arrival in 2001 of
the first group of fellows
at the new Radcliffe
Institute, women
have comprised a majority
of every fellowship class,
today consisting of 50
scientists, humanists,
social scientists,
and artists who
are diverse in many
other ways as well.
We also help the university
bring new talent and diversity
to the faculty through the
Radcliffe Professorships
program, which recruits
tenured and untenured faculty
to Harvard schools by
offering them the opportunity
to spend one or two years in
residence as Radcliffe Fellows.
And our public
programming frequently
examines important
issues related to gender,
often exploring how
gender intersects
with other identities.
For example, our annual
gender conferences
have focused on such topics as
immigration, violence, sports,
the Arab Spring, public health,
and coming up this April,
citizenship.
We have also organized symposia
on subjects like gender
and family in the
global refugee crisis,
or women and the lack of them
in the booming biotech sector.
And of course, one of
Radcliffe's three core programs
is the Schlesinger
Library on the history
of women in America, which Jane
Kamensky is Faculty Director.
The Schlesinger's mission
since its founding
75 years ago has been to
collect the papers of women
and their organizations
to document
the history of American
women, gender, and society
for the present
and for the future.
At this moment in its
history, we are particularly
focused on broadening the
Schlesinger's collections
so that they reflect
the varied experiences
of all American women.
As you may know, the Schlesinger
with its rich archives
on the history of
Radcliffe College
was a critical
resource for Nancy
in pursuing the work that
you will be discussing
with us this afternoon.
Today Nancy will help
us better understand
a critical moment in our
own Radcliffe history, which
she has analyzed so insightfully
in her recent book entitled
Keep the Damned Women Out: The
Struggle Towards Coeducation.
That title-- the Keep the
Damned Women Out part--
is a quotation from one
particularly agitated
Dartmouth alumnus.
And it provides a clue into
the intensity of emotion
that surrounded this enormous
change in the nation's most
elite colleges--
private colleges.
Thanks to Nancy's deep
research and engaging writing,
we can listen in on the
complex institutional decision
making and the internal
and external debates that
swirled around the question
of coeducation at Harvard
and Radcliffe and also Yale,
Princeton, Dartmouth, Oxford,
Cambridge, and the elite private
women's colleges of Vassar,
Smith, and Wellesley.
At first glance, it might
seem that the bastions
of male privilege and
prestige that Nancy examines
embrace coeducation
almost overnight.
Indeed, they all
began accepting women
within just a few years of 1969.
And looking back on all the
other social and political
changes underway in
the 1960s, coeducation
could almost seem inevitable.
But focusing in on
that watershed moment
masks that much more protracted
evolution that both preceded
and followed it.
Similarly, popular memory tends
to focus on public events,
and in the process misses
the more private debates
and negotiations that are
critical to large-scale
institutional changes, like
the introduction of coeducation
at elite universities.
Nancy makes none
of these mistakes.
With the historian's long
view and penetrating gaze,
she helps us understand that
like all social revolutions,
the achievement
of women's access
to privileged male
universities resulted
from multiple levels of
causation, both persistent,
drawn out rumblings and shorter
fuse catalysts and triggers.
And while some of the
struggles played out in public,
other key moments took
place behind closed doors
and until now were
buried in the archives.
Most importantly, as
the good historian
she is, Nancy
knows that there is
no such thing as inevitability.
As she writes in a
deliberately understated way,
and I quote, "No
matter how powerful
the influence of the times,
the coming of coeducation
was not a smooth, easy,
uncontested process.
We at Radcliffe know
that especially well.
When Elizabeth Cary Agassiz
founded Radcliffe College,
she thought of it
as a stopgap measure
until Harvard embraced
coeducation, which she expected
would happen very soon.
It only took a century."
Looking around this room,
I am aware that many of us
personally experienced the
struggle for coeducation
or were part of
early coed classes.
Whenever I have
discussed Nancy's book
with contemporaries,
I have heard
versions of the same comment.
Reading this book
helped me understand
what I lived through.
That is certainly true for me.
Co-incidentally, Nancy and
I both arrived at Princeton
in the fall of 1969.
I was a member of the first
coeducational freshman
class at Princeton.
And I would go on to
become a history major.
And Nancy was a new
assistant professor
and the first woman
faculty member
in the History Department.
She may not remember
this, but I recall first
meeting her at a party at
Professor Carl Schorske's
house.
He and his wife Liz were
newcomers themselves
to Princeton,
having arrived from
the great and coeducational
public university of UC
Berkeley.
And they were
determined to help make
Princeton a more comfortable
place for both sexes.
Hence, they reached
out to welcome
women, both students
and faculty,
into their home, a pleasurable
experience for me as a student,
and I would venture
for Nancy too
as one of the very few women
on the Princeton faculty.
From her first appointment
in the History Department,
Nancy went on to rise
through the academic ranks
at Princeton, eventually
serving as dean
of the college for a
remarkable 24 years.
It was particularly exciting
for me to watch Nancy as dean
when my own daughter
Julia was an undergraduate
in the class of 2009.
By then, Princeton had
become a much more normal
coeducational
environment, thanks
in great part to Nancy's
commitment and contributions.
As an accomplished
university administrator
and a distinguished historian
of 20th Century America,
Nancy was uniquely
qualified to write this book
and to guide readers
through a complex history
of institutional change.
Nonetheless, it took tremendous
courage and determination
to apply every arrow in
the historian's quiver
to analyzing deeply
and subtly a world
she knew well as a player,
but not as a scholar.
Nancy is currently professor
emeritus in Princeton's History
Department and the author
of several important books.
Keep the Damned Women Out
was published last year.
And it has received
critical acclaim,
including the 2017 PROSE
Award in education practice
from the Association
of American Publishers.
Before that, Nancy
was the author
of Whitney M. Young, Jr., and
the Struggle for Civil Rights,
Farewell to the
Party of Lincoln:
Black Politics in
the Age of FDR,
and The National Urban
League, 1910 to 1940.
It is a tremendous
pleasure for me
to have Nancy here
with us today.
Please join me in welcoming
her to the podium.
[APPLAUSE]
- You're terrific.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I am so honored to be here.
I should really just
sit down after Liz's
remarkable introduction.
She's told you
plenty about my book.
One of the reasons
I'm amazed to be here
is that I studied American
History at Harvard
in the era of Buck, Hanlon,
[INAUDIBLE],, Friedel, Fleming,
May.
And American History at Harvard
today, Faust, Cohen, Kamensky,
Cott, Ulrich, McGirr,
Higginbotham, and I've
left out a whole bunch of them.
I could never for a
moment have imagined what
a transformation has occurred.
I have three objectives
this afternoon.
The first is to examine
the flood of decisions
for coeducation at highly
prestigious colleges
and universities in
the United States
and the United Kingdom in
the period 1969 to '74.
The second is to locate Harvard
and Radcliffe in that context.
And the third is to
make some observations
about the relationship
of coeducation
to the significant
challenges that
remain in terms of
the education of women
and the barriers women
continue to face,
not only in higher education,
but in the professions
and public life.
I'll begin then with the
decisions for coeducation
in the period 1969 to 1974.
Coeducation came all of a
sudden to very traditional,
very conservative,
very elite, very old
colleges and universities like
Yale, Princeton, and Dartmouth.
It came to men's colleges
at Cambridge and Oxford.
And it came to dozens of other
colleges and universities
as well.
Well why did this happen?
And why then?
What hurdles had to
be overcome to open
the doors of highly prestigious
institutions to women?
And how well did coeducation
work in its early years?
Coeducation happened
in the United States
because it was in
the strategic self
interest of all-male
institutions like Princeton
and Yale to admit women.
By the late 1960s,
these schools were
beginning to see their
applications decline along
with their yields.
The high school students these
schools called the best boys
no longer wanted to go
to all-male institutions.
So the key issue was
the ability to continue
to attract those best boys.
And this is, by the
way, when Harvard
begins to pull away
from Yale and Princeton
in the competition for the
best high school students.
I hadn't realized that.
I thought Harvard
was always ahead.
But it wasn't true.
Up till the early 1960s,
the three went head-to-head.
And Harvard, with
Radcliffe up the street,
had something that these best
high school boys wanted, which
is to say proximity to women.
So coeducation became the
means for places like Princeton
and Yale to shore up a
first-rate applicant pool
and enrolled student body.
It was not the result of a
high-minded moral commitment
to opening educational
opportunities to women.
It was not a matter of a
mission to educate women.
It was not the result
of deep thinking
about how to educate women.
Rather, it was about
what women would
do for previously
all-male institutions,
about how women would
help these schools renew
their hold on the best boys.
Women, in other words,
played the instrumental role
of improving the educational
experience of men.
While my story this afternoon
focuses on the United States,
I might note
parenthetically that you
see a variant of strategic
self interest at Cambridge
and Oxford, where the decision
by particular colleges
to take the lead in going
mixed was prompted in part
by a desire to get
better students
and increase their prestige
relative to the other colleges
in the two universities.
Returning to the
United States, I
want to point out that the
protagonists in this story
are men.
Save for Polly Bunting,
the extraordinary president
of Radcliffe, every strategist,
every decision maker,
everyone leading the charge
for coeducation was male.
Coeducation resulted not
from organized efforts
by women activists, but
from strategic decisions
taken by powerful men.
Why did coeducation
happen when it did?
Changes in application
patterns were a trigger,
but the larger context of
the 1960s set the stage.
The civil rights movement,
the antiwar movements,
student movement,
the women's movement.
By the end of the 1960s,
colleges and universities
looked quite different
than they had
in the beginning of the decade.
The composition
of student bodies
began to change to include a
larger number of public school
students, students from
less advantaged families,
Catholic students,
Jewish students, even
some African Americans.
So in a way, admitting
women followed logically.
As well, men and women students
in the 1960s demonstrated
together, protested together,
registered black voters
together.
Not going to school together
seemed increasingly outmoded.
And all of this,
of course, bears
on why high school students
changed their minds
about the attractiveness
of all-male schools.
Princeton and Yale were the
prime movers in this process.
Everyone else was watching
and taking cues from them.
They were driven by the
forces I've just described,
especially admissions.
But they were also acting
in direct competition
with one another.
And you don't have
to infer that.
It's right there in
the archival materials.
Let me make just a
few comments about how
that competition worked.
Kingman Brewster started it off.
He, in December
of 1966, announced
with Alan Simpson, the
president of Vassar College,
that the two
institutions would engage
in a serious study of the
possibility of moving Vassar
from Poughkeepsie to New Haven.
And that study unfolded
over the next 11 months.
President, trustees,
administrators, faculty, alums,
students all engaged
in one way or another.
So when Bob Goheen at Princeton
found out that Brewster was,
if you will, courting
Vassar, his first response
was to go up to Sarah
Lawrence College
to talk to Esther Raushenbush,
the president of Sarah
Lawrence, about the possibility
of Sarah Lawrence and Princeton
engaging in a similar
study of moving
Sarah Lawrence to
Princeton, an unlikelier
match I can't imagine.
Bob Goheen's more serious
response to Vassar-Yale
was to ask the trustees
for authorization
to undertake a serious
data-driven analytic study
of the desirability and
feasibility of coeducation
for Princeton.
And he asked Gardner
Patterson, an economist
on the faculty of the
Woodrow Wilson School,
to carry the study forward.
And that work began
in the summer of 1967
and continued through
the summer of 1968.
Well, after Vassar
said no to Yale,
Kingman Brewster said,
well, maybe we'll
establish our own women's
college, a coordinate women's
college.
And he spent most of
the next 10 months
or so musing in a desultory
sort of way about what
that college for women might
involve, but not much happened.
Then in September of
1968, the Patterson Report
was published in the
Princeton Alumni Weekly
and widely distributed, and
a copy arrived in New Haven.
And Brewster read
it, and he realized
that Princeton might actually
be serious about coeducation.
And within two months, Brewster
got the Yale corporation
and the Yale faculty to
vote in favor of coeducation
for September 1969.
There was no process
and no planning.
And it was a direct
response to the possibility
that Princeton might
get there first.
So at the point when the Yale
folks vote for coeducation,
Princeton is engaged in careful,
deliberate, consultative
process discussing the--
first they had a trustee
committee evaluating
the Patterson Report.
Then they discussed
it with alumni
around the country
in regional meetings.
The Princeton trustees took
their first vote on coeducation
in January of 1969 as Yale
was reading applications
from women students.
And they agreed in principle
to support coeducation
and told Goheen to come
back when he was ready,
tell them how he would do it.
So he comes back in
late April of 1969
and explains how
Princeton would do it.
Now understand Yale
has already admitted
its first class of women.
If this had been done Princeton
style, what the Princeton
trustees would have decided
in late April of 1969
was that coeducation would
come in the fall of 1970.
Lots of time for
planning and getting
organized, but that
wasn't possible.
Women were coming to
Yale in the fall of 1969.
And so they were coming
to Princeton in September
after a decision in late April.
Let me turn now to
the hurdles that
had to be overcome to open the
doors of these institutions
to women.
No matter which institution
we're talking about,
it would be difficult to
overestimate how tough it
was to make coeducation happen.
There was fierce
opposition from alumni,
as well as
significant resistance
from many faculty and students.
Some examples
illustrate the point.
Liz has already commented
on the title of my book,
Keep the Damned Women Out.
The letter from the
Dartmouth alumnus class
of 1929 to the chair of the
Dartmouth trustees in 1970
said, for God's sake,
for Dartmouth's sake,
and for everyone's sake,
keep the damned women out.
Consider an example from Yale
when the Yale corporation first
opined publicly on the education
of undergraduate women,
one alumnus responded this way.
There was a glory to tradition.
I think of the girl-filled
weekend, the cocktail party,
the dances, the plays,
the big football games.
Then there was the
adventure of journeying
to the girls colleges.
And gentlemen, he
said, let's face it.
Charming as women are,
they get to be a drag
if you are forced to associate
with them each and every day.
Think of the poor student
who has a steady date.
He wants to concentrate
on the basic principles
of thermodynamics, but
she keeps trying to gossip
about all the idiotic trivia
all women try to impose on men.
Consider some examples
from Princeton.
One alumnus wondered
why this death
wish on the part of Princeton.
If women were admitted, he said
no doubt a very fine school
would emerge, but
Princeton University
would be lost forever.
Another alumnus said
that coeducation
would dilute Princeton's sturdy
masculinity with disconcerting
mini-skirted young things
cavorting on its playing
fields.
So another alumnus
put it this way.
What is all this nonsense about
admitting women to Princeton?
The good, old-fashioned
whorehouse
would be considerably more
efficient and much, much
cheaper.
As for faculty, some
were supportive.
Some were opposed.
But virtually everyone put the
newly admitted women students
on the spot by asking for
the woman's point of view,
no matter whether the course
was in literature or psychology
where such a view might
have been relevant,
or in math or physics
where it surely wasn't.
I would put that in the category
of bumbling but relatively
innocent faculty behavior.
But not all faculty behavior
could be described that way.
Consider the art history
professor at Dartmouth
who posted slides of nudes on
the screen, running his hand up
and down their thighs, or the
oceanography professor who
showed pictures of sea
creatures, shrimp, lobster,
squid, and naked women.
Or consider the response of the
chair of the History Department
at Yale, asked by
a woman freshman
if the department might offer
a course in women's history.
That, he said, would be like
teaching the history of dogs.
Students were not
always much better
about welcoming their
female classmates.
Male students often told
their female counterparts
that they really didn't
belong on their campuses
and they should go back
wherever they came from.
Dartmouth offers the
most striking examples
of bad behavior.
Dartmouth men hung banners from
dormitory windows, no coeds,
coeds go home.
They shouted out numbers meant
as ratings of attractiveness
as women entered the dining
hall, as if they were
rating the quality of a dive.
Fraternities delighted
in and got away
with drunken, degrading,
dangerous behaviors
and scurrilous verbal
assaults on women students.
My favorite Dartmouth example
comes from the third year
of coeducation.
Dartmouth then-- who
knows, maybe now--
had a tradition, an
event in the spring
called Hums, which
was a competition
among the fraternities, who
composed and then performed
original songs.
And this year the winning
entry in that Hums competition
was the song Our
Co-Hogs, 10 verses
of outrageously insulting
sexualized attacks on women.
Co-hog was a highly derogatory
nickname for women students.
And the judge of the competition
was the dean of the college.
And he delighted not only
in calling Our Co-Hogs
the very best
submission of the year,
but he then stood up with
the members of the fraternity
in an exuberant public
rendition of the song.
He then left to become
president of a women's college.
Moving next to my second
major theme for the afternoon.
What can we say about
Harvard and Radcliffe
in the context of the cascade
of decisions for coeducation?
And I can't fail to
comment in this setting
on the critical role of
the Schlesinger Library
in enabling the
telling of this story
by allowing me to circumvent
the constraints of Harvard's
50-year rule on access
to institutional records,
like the papers of the
president, the corporation,
and so on.
It's all in the Schlesinger.
And-
[LAUGHTER]
At any rate, so back to my
subject with a disclaimer.
To say that I am diffident
about telling a distinguished
Radcliffe audience what I
make of Radcliffe's history
is a significant understatement.
But that's what
I've signed on for.
You will surely have noticed
how rarely I spoke of Harvard
in the story I just recounted.
By all rights, in
my view, Harvard
would have been the
logical first mover
in the coming of coeducation.
As this Radcliffe
audience knows very well,
Radcliffe was a half mile
up the street from Harvard
with students whose
academic qualifications
fully matched if
not over matched
those of Harvard students.
Radcliffe women had been
taking classes with Harvard men
since the 1940s.
The colleges had merged most
of their extracurricular
activities in the 1950s.
The presidents of both
institutions were enthusiastic.
But realizing
coeducation in Cambridge
turned out to be a surprisingly
complicated endeavor.
Polly Bunting and
Nathan Pusey began
talking about coeducation
almost from the moment
that Bunting took up the
presidency of Radcliffe
in 1960.
It was clear to her that in
terms of the overall richness
and effectiveness of
undergraduate education,
Radcliffe women were at a
significant disadvantage
in comparison with Harvard men.
That was evident in every way--
in residential life, in
relations with faculty members,
in access to resources,
in facilities.
And Bunting's
proposed solution was
to make Radcliffe
part of Harvard
with Harvard taking
responsibility
for undergraduate education.
Only then, she
thought, would Harvard
become what she called
a university in which
the educational
potentialities of women
are valued and met as
fully as those of men.
It sounds straightforward.
But it was in no way
simple to achieve.
Although functional coeducation
would be realized by 1972,
a formal merger between
Harvard and Radcliffe
would not be
concluded until 1999.
Understanding the long,
often tortuous path to merger
I think requires reckoning
with the deep investment
of Radcliffe trustees and
alumni and the history
and prestige of their college.
Relinquishing any part of
that, indeed compromising
the institution's
fundamental independence,
was not to be
undertaken lightly.
A series of steps taken in
the 1960s and early 1970s,
mainly at Bunting's
initiative but with Pusey's
full cooperation, brought
Harvard and Radcliffe
closer together.
Harvard first began
awarding degrees
to Radcliffe's students,
graduate and undergraduate,
in 1963.
In 1966, the Harvard
registrar's office
took over Radcliffe
undergraduate registration,
including course
enrollments, maintenance
of academic records, and
issuance of transcripts.
In 1967, Harvard opened its
undergraduate library, Lamont,
to Radcliffe women who had
been excluded for decades.
With Yale and
Princeton embarking
on coeducation and Harvard and
Radcliffe students lobbying
for coeducation, the
Radcliffe governing boards
voted in February of 1969
to initiate discussions
with Harvard with
[? a view to ?] merging the two
institutions.
The Crimson declared
in a banner headline,
Cliffe finally proposes marriage
to 10,000 men of Harvard.
The Harvard Corporation
responded affirmatively.
"We can say at once,"
Pusey wrote to Bunting,
"that in principle we welcome
the prospect of a merger.
We should be happy
to join with you
in discussion of when and how
a merger might be effected."
Well, as you well know,
it took another 30 years
for that to happen.
What were Pusey and
Bunting able to accomplish?
And what prevented
them from realizing
the merger both of them
would have liked to achieve?
By the time Pusey retired
from the Harvard presidency
in 1971, he had succeeded
in admitting to Harvard,
to the Graduate School of
Arts and Sciences, women
who would otherwise have
matriculated for graduate study
at Radcliffe.
On his watch, Harvard had
begun awarding degrees
to all Radcliffe students.
Radcliffe students
had begun taking part
in Harvard commencement
ceremonies.
The separate administrative
boards had been dissolved
and a joint Harvard-Radcliffe
administrative board
established.
And Harvard and Radcliffe had
embarked on the early stages
of co-residential living.
In other words, undergraduates
at Harvard and Radcliffe
studied together in
the same classes,
had the option of living
in the same dormitories,
participated in the same
extracurricular activities,
graduated in the same
commencement ceremonies,
and earned the same
bachelor's degrees.
The same accomplishments
could also
be credited to
Polly Bunting, who
had seen to the creation of
a Radcliffe house system,
the renovation of
existing dormitories
and the building of a new
set of residential facilities
at Currier House, the
integration of faculty
and tutors into
Radcliffe houses,
and the building of
Phyllis Library, which
served Radcliffe women
and also attracted Harvard
men to the Radcliffe quad.
Moreover, Polly Bunting
had created the Radcliffe
Institute, later the Bunting
Institute, later later
later the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study.
But the Radcliffe Institute
then was a pioneering vehicle
through which talented
adult women had the time,
opportunity, and
support to engage fully
in intellectual pursuits
or creative work that would
shape their lives and careers.
But going all the way to
merger eluded Pusey and Bunting
no matter how eager they
were to accomplish it.
The remaining anomaly at
Harvard and Radcliffe--
two separate corporate
structures with separate
governing boards,
endowments, budgets,
and administrative
arrangements--
had not been addressed
before Pusey left office.
Why was that the case?
On the Harvard side, the
faculty of Arts and Sciences
was simply not ready to
take full responsibility
for Radcliffe students.
To put it perhaps
more charitably,
to be party to the disappearance
of Radcliffe College.
Pusey's own freedom of action
was limited in significant part
by Vietnam War-related
turmoil that
rocked the Harvard campus
from late November 1966
through April 1969.
Calling in the police
to clear University
Hall in the wake of the
student takeover in April 1969
had been hugely
controversial with damage
to Pusey's credibility
in the corporation
as well as with the faculty.
It also resulted in the
foreshortening of Pusey's term
as president, which ended in
June 1971, two years before it
was originally intended
to come to a close.
Buffeted by forces
largely external
to Harvard, unable smoothly to
manage the university amidst
the turmoil that those
forces caused on campus,
Pusey lost the authority
and the maneuvering room
to lean on the Harvard
faculty to embrace
the internal rearrangements
required for merger.
And Bunting, of course, had
no independent authority
over the Harvard faculty.
So she could not
herself have led them
to a different conclusion.
Moreover, Bunting had
trustees and alumni leaders
who were deeply skeptical of
Harvard, a skepticism well
grounded in the reality
of Harvard's history.
Since 1948, Harvard had had
one tenured woman faculty
member who held a tenured
position created specifically
for a woman.
There were a handful of
women assistant professors,
but there was no past tenure
from the assistant professor
ranks.
Harvard had no women
administrators.
And the number of male
undergraduates at Harvard
was four times the number
of Radcliffe women.
So there was reasonable
cause to worry
about submerging Radcliffe into
a less-than-hospitable male
university.
Becoming part of Harvard without
losing Radcliffe's identity
was beyond the imagination of
many of Radcliffe's leaders.
And that identity
mattered a lot.
In part it mattered
substantively.
Radcliffe leaders worried that
women would be treated poorly
by Harvard unless
Radcliffe hung in
to protect them, to
advocate for them,
and to see them through to
a successful educational
experience.
In part, and I would
argue in large part,
it mattered symbolically.
Radcliffe leaders and
Radcliffe alumni more
generally felt a strong
emotional attachment
to a storied history.
Radcliffe had long
been understood
to be preeminent among
the Seven Sisters.
Going to Radcliffe,
being a Radcliffe alumna
conveyed a status that mattered
hugely to Radcliffe graduates.
Long past the point
where Radcliffe actually
functioned as a college,
the abstract idea
of Radcliffe College
had a powerful hold
on people who believed in
Radcliffe, who loved Radcliffe,
who were firmly convinced that
Radcliffe stood for something
that could not be sacrificed.
Moreover, keeping
Radcliffe intact
was seen as a feminist act.
As a group of alumni
leaders put it,
a separate Radcliffe
would continue
to make useful contributions
to the education of women.
Emerged Radcliffe,
they said, would
silence an eloquent champion
of educational opportunities
for women.
So the 1970s began with the
non-merger merger, an agreement
signed by Polly
Bunting and Derek Bok
just after Bok succeeded
Pusey in the summer of 1971.
It stipulated that Harvard
would take responsibility
for operating the
Radcliffe houses as part
of the unified house system,
that Harvard would manage
the business
operations of Radcliffe
including dining services,
buildings and grounds,
and the controller's office.
The agreement said further
that Radcliffe would turn over
to Harvard its
unrestricted endowment
income, current undesignated
gifts, and the small percentage
of tuition income that it
had retained, all of which
Harvard would then use to pay
Radcliffe's operating expenses.
Radcliffe would
retain responsibility
for the Institute, for the
Schlesinger Library, career
counseling, and
the alumni office.
And it would retain
ownership of its property
and manage its endowment.
That is where things stood
when Matina Horner became
president of Radcliffe in 1972.
Influenced by
second-wave feminism,
Horner also brought to bear
her own important scholarship
on women's fear of success.
And she believed
that Polly Bunting
had gone too far in folding
Radcliffe into Harvard.
She believed that it
was important to sustain
Radcliffe's corporate
independence
and that financial deal
that Bunting and Bok struck
was not to
Radcliffe's advantage.
Considerable work was done
between the two institutions
to try to work out terms
for further cooperation.
But in November of 1976,
the Radcliffe trustees
called a halt and
declared that Radcliffe
would remain an
independent institution
to carry out programs to promote
the higher education of women.
And in 1977, Horner and
Bok signed a new agreement
laying out the terms of
a continuing coordinate
relationship whereby
Radcliffe would remain legally
independent of Harvard,
would play stipulated roles
in seeing to the well-being
of women at Harvard,
and would take back at
least symbolic if not
actual control of
fiscal matters that had
been seated to Harvard in 1971.
And that is where things stood
when Linda Wilson succeeded
Matina Horner as
president in 1989
and Neil Rudenstine
succeeded Derek Bok in 1991.
With Rudenstine's
urging in cooperation
not only with Wilson, but
with Nancy-Beth Gordon
Sheer, the chair of
the Radcliffe trustees,
Harvard and Radcliffe signed
yet another agreement in 1999
merging the two
institutions and providing
for the establishment of
the Radcliffe Institute
for Advanced Study,
under whose aegis
we were gathered this afternoon.
Let me turn finally
to my third theme,
the question of
what can be learned
from the fight for coeducation
as we think about breaking
through the barriers
women continue
to face in higher education, the
professions, and public life.
I'm going to focus
on higher education.
Many of you know more than
I do about the professions.
And I find this a
particularly dispiriting time
to talk about barriers
to women in public life.
The first thing to say is
that the fight for coeducation
shows us, I think, that
institutional change is
really hard to accomplish.
And this is a
controversial point.
I think it shows us
that it is more likely
that institutional
change will happen when
it is in the clear
interest of the men who
run the institutions.
In other words, protesting
or storming the barricades
probably won't get
you all the way there.
My second point is that
coeducation actually
accomplished a lot,
but at the same time
there was a lot that it did not
accomplish and could not have
been expected to accomplish.
As for what it accomplished,
the one incontrovertible point
is that coeducation has opened
educational opportunities
for women that had not
previously existed.
Being able to attend
previously all-male colleges
and universities has
given women access
to a broader range of
educational opportunities.
Women now have full access, as
men do, to the best university
education in the
Anglo American world,
to faculty members
at the cutting
edge of their
respective disciplines,
as well as to the best
libraries, laboratories,
and other educational
facilities.
And women students
have the opportunity
to profit from the intellectual
stimulation and interchange as
well as the social interactions
fostered in mixed sex
educational environments.
Going to school
together means learning
to live and work together.
And in the 21st Century,
as you well know,
most college-bound students
see coeducational environments
as more normal than
environments segregated by sex.
But then comes the but.
And in any major social
change, it's usually the case
that there is a but.
If we consider the impact
of coeducation on colleges
and universities, the first
point to be made, I think,
is that coeducation did
not mean revolution.
Women were added to the mix.
But the institutions
themselves proved
to be remarkably durable.
And women generally accepted
or embraced traditions
rather than challenging
and up-ending them.
In the United States
and the United Kingdom,
women were included,
assimilated, accepted.
Colleges and universities
were flexible enough
to accommodate them,
but not so flexible
that the institutions became
unrecognizable compared
with their former selves.
The second important
point, I think,
is that coeducation
accompanied but did not
cause more profound
social transformations
in these colleges
and universities.
And by that, I mean diversity
in terms of race, ethnicity,
and socioeconomic background.
Elite education
in the late 1960s
began to be less aristocratic
and more democratic
or meritocratic.
But that happened
in parallel with,
not as a result of coeducation.
Now for all the gains
realized through coeducation,
it's important to be clear about
what coeducation has not done
and I think should not
have been expected to do.
Coeducation has not resolved
the longstanding complexities
in relations between
men and women.
To be explicit, sexual
harassment and sexual assault
are no more under control
after almost a half century
of coeducation than they
were when men and women first
started going to
college together.
And one has only
to look to Harvard
and this very afternoon's
faculty of Arts and Sciences
deliberations to appreciate
the frustrating tenacity
of structures within which
men associate with one another
for social purposes in ways that
exclude and objectify women,
where gender discrimination
and sexual harassment
are built into the fabric of
institutions, institutions
that long predate coeducation.
And I could easily
broaden the observation
and change the focus
to the inimical effects
on women of gender segregation
in the professional world.
Think Silicon Valley, to
take a current example,
where again gender
discrimination
and sexual harassment
seem to be built
into the fabric of
institutions, but in this case
institutions that
are quite new, that
were created well after the wave
of decisions for coeducation.
To move to another
sphere, I would
note that coeducation
has not resolved
the perplexingly gendered
behaviors and aspirations
of female students.
Look at the Duke
Women's Initiative
in 2003, the Princeton
steering committee
on undergraduate women's
leadership in 2011, telling us
about gender patterns in terms
of women in leadership, sex
stereotyping,
gendered social norms,
differential patterns
of academic achievement
among men and women.
Coeducation has not
resolved the conundrum
of gendered fields
of study, especially
the persistent
under-representation
of undergraduate
women in such fields
as computer science,
economics, math, and physics.
Nor has coeducation balanced the
highly skewed gender patterns
among college and university
faculty and graduate students.
And coeducation
has certainly not
ensured that women alumni can
expect professional careers
that parallel those of men.
Despite the ample supply
of female graduates
of highly prestigious,
previously
all-male institutions,
women continue
to face challenges in
finding leadership positions
and professional advancement.
And pressing issues
remain in the area
of work-family balance.
In short, while we are rightly
to celebrate the achievements
of coeducation, we should
remind ourselves, I think,
that coeducation at the most
elite colleges and universities
did not solve and could
not have been expected
to solve persistently
challenging
personal and social
issues that continue
to have a profound
influence on opportunities
as well as gender relations
in American society.
Let me stop there I'd
be delighted to take
your questions.
[APPLAUSE]
Yes.
- My name is Amanda Cross.
I entered Radcliffe
in the class of '69.
I've always been interested in--
I was a applied math major.
I'm a numbers person.
How different were
the SAT scores
between the males being
admitted to Radcliffe
and the males being
admitted to Harvard
and the women being
admitted to Radcliffe?
It's always been
interesting to me to--
because of that quota you talked
about, the four to one ratio.
How different was it?
Is that something that
anybody ever tracked?
- Well, look.
The question has to do with
the difference in the SAT
scores between Radcliffe
students and Harvard students.
I would describe that
difference the way
I would describe the credentials
of the first women who
entered Princeton or Yale
compared with the men there.
In the case of the men, the
credentials look like that.
In the case of the women,
they look like that.
- Yes.
I assumed that, but I've just
never seen it in writing.
Thank you.
- When I said Radcliffe women
matched if not over-matched
Harvard men, they really
were at the top end
of the distribution.
- I'm Kendra Stearns O'Donnell.
And I arrived at Princeton
on the faculty in 1971
and looked up to you.
But I remember
how very difficult
it was not only for the
few women on the faculty,
but also for the first coeds.
And I am struck by your point
that the decision to go coed
was so abrupt and had
really so little planning
in terms of how the culture or
how the community might have
to change to bring women in.
And do you think that the
history of coeducation
in these elite institutions
would have been different
had there been
years of planning,
had people really worked out
the residential piece, all
the rest of it?
- I think the problem
is that the people who
were doing the deliberating and
making the decisions were men.
And they really didn't
know how to think
about the education of women.
If you look at the
Patterson Report,
a very careful, thorough,
sober, sensible analysis--
it's a long report.
And less than one
full page relates
to whether Princeton could
do justice to women students.
And it meanders in
so many directions
that you just have no idea what
Gardner Patterson is thinking.
I think the problem
is that Kingman
Brewster and his colleagues
moved faster than Princeton.
But they had the same
problem that Bob Goheen
and Bill Bowen and their
colleagues had at Princeton.
They just didn't know.
And they tried to
inform themselves.
They brought in outside
experts, Polly Bunting
and some distinguished
women educators
from other institutions,
to talk about how to do it.
What decisions did
you need to make?
What arrangements
did you need to make?
But they just didn't know.
And their assumption was
they would figure it out.
When the women students
arrived, the women students
would essentially tell them
what they wanted and needed.
So I think even if they had
had a long time to plan,
they wouldn't have
known how to do it,
because they were in the
business of educating men.
- I'm Lewis Counts, an MIT grad
married to a Radcliffe grad.
You mentioned Berkeley as
one of the great land grant
schools along with Illinois,
who a century before the schools
had seemed to have been
cordoned off by the Hudson River
for many kind of reason,
decided to admit women.
Now, was there any
discussion that you
found of how things were
going at Berkeley or Illinois
or Ohio or other great schools?
I would argue in
many ways greater,
because they've educated more
people on the east coast.
Was there any awareness?
You were talking about planning.
There were ample role
models and success stories.
- You have to understand
that Harvard, Yale,
and Princeton don't
normally think
in terms of Illinois and Ohio.
It's just not the way it works.
They did visit a
lot of institutions.
Stanford was the
coed institution
most often considered
as somehow analogous.
Chicago was considered.
But it would not
have dawned on them
really to look at the
experience that a lot
of major universities,
which they didn't think
were like them.
What's really interesting about
some of the universities that
went coed in the 19th Century--
interesting to me-- is
how complicated it was.
Let's take the cases of Stanford
and Chicago, both of them
coeducational from the outset.
In the case of
Chicago, the problem
was that too many
women were enrolling
and they were doing too well.
And Chicago was a
new university and it
depended on important
philanthropy in the city.
And the assumption was that if
the place was overrun by women,
they'd never be able to raise
money to support the place.
So they put in place
a cockamamie scheme
to separate women and men
in the introductory courses
and then let them
study together later.
Well that withered away.
At Stanford, it's founded
as a coed institution
by Leland and Jane Stanford
in memory of their young son
who had died.
By the time Stanford
starts up in the 1890s,
Leland Stanford has died.
So Jane Stanford
is the actor here.
And what she sees
is the same thing.
There are too many women
coming to Stanford,
and they are doing too well.
And if you let that continue
to happen, for goodness sakes,
what kind of a
memorial will this
be to young Leland Stanford?
So she sees to it that they
impose a cap of 500 women
students in the student body.
And that stays in place
until the 1930s when it gets
relaxed a little because
of the depression.
And it's really
not till the 1960s
that things get equalized.
Wesleyan University tries
admitting women in the 1870s.
The exact same thing.
Too many women,
they're doing too well.
And the Wesleyan
trustees respond
in the early years of the 20th
Century by kicking them out.
And women alums of Wesleyan
found Connecticut College
for Women.
Berkeley is a complicated story.
Cornell, another early
coed institution,
is a complicated story.
Michigan, another
early coed institution.
There's a lot of separating
of women from men
and a lot of gendered
arrangements and behaviors.
It's not a smooth,
easy story here.
- Hi.
I'm Julie Anderson.
I was a graduate in
1971 from Radcliffe.
And actually you answered
pretty much my question.
I come from California.
And so I wondered is your
analysis of coeducation--
does it apply from the east
coast to these Western schools?
And as you've said.
But those rather
dispiriting statistics
at the end of your talk that
it doesn't really change
our culture's idea about women.
Do we know that that's true from
some of those Western schools
as well?
Do we have that
same set of outcomes
that it hasn't really changed
the institutions that much?
- Look, I'm looking nationally.
I'm looking at women in
the professions, women
in public life.
How women fare in
major corporations
and financial
institutions, for example,
is not a regional phenomenon.
It's a national phenomenon.
So I think we've got problems
that are not regional--
- That are enduring.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Wonderful talk.
- Thank you.
- Hello.
My name is Lisa Goldman.
And I was in the second
class of freshmen
to be admitted to Yale
that contained women.
And thank you.
You've explained
why everything--
there was no--
I now understand why
there was nothing
for women when we got there.
I've always wondered about that.
My question for you is, we
still have a long way to go.
And I think even within
all of these institutions,
even though they
are now coeducated,
we still have a long way to go.
And I am wondering--
and we now know that separate
but equal does not work.
I'm wondering what
recommendations
you would make as the
result of your research
as to how we can
arrive at a more
equitable society in general.
It's a big-- I apologize.
It's a big question.
But I'm wondering if you
drew any conclusions that
could guide us in trying
to move in that direction.
- Look, I'm an historian.
I am not--
[LAUGHTER]
- You must have
learned something
from all your research.
- I think-- no.
Let me tell you a couple
of small examples.
It took Nan Keohane at the
end of her presidency of Duke
to establish the Women's
Initiative to look
into the differential experience
of men and women at Duke,
even though Duke had been
functionally coed for decades
by then.
The whole business of
effortless perfection
as undergraduate women
saw the self-fashioning
that they had to engage in.
It took Shirley Tilghman as
president of Princeton in 2011
to say, wait a minute.
Women students are not
presenting themselves
for the highest profile
leadership positions on campus.
And while women in general are
outperforming men academically,
at the very, very top
the men have a lock
on the highest achievement.
What's going on here?
I think in part, having issues
raised to public visibility
and impanelling people to work
on them makes a difference.
It certainly has made
some difference at Duke
and some difference
at Princeton.
Can you generalize from that?
Of course not.
I mean, for goodness sakes.
The debate Anne-Marie Slaughter
and Sheryl Sandberg about
work-family balance, leaning
in and all the rest--
I don't know how you fix that.
The revelations
we've been seeing
from companies in Silicon
Valley about the way they
treat women--
My husband just gave me a
paper from the National Bureau
of Economic Research
on men and women
who are financial advisers.
And women are less
represented in the ranks
of financial advisors.
They're paid less.
And they're disciplined more
often for misbehavior than men.
Well, how do you reform an
industry or a corporation?
I don't know the answer to that.
But public attention
and discussion
is certainly an
important beginning.
- My name is Philip Lynch.
I'm also an MIT graduate.
So I wonder if it says
anything that the two
men in line for questions
both graduated from MIT.
And also I want
to recall the fact
that MIT has been coed from
sometime in the latter half
of the 1800s.
And I wonder if it
had the problems
that Stanford and Chicago
complained about in terms
of alumni contributions.
But that's not my question.
My question is the experience
of Columbia and Barnard,
which I understand considered
merging and decided not to
and then Columbia went coed--
I wonder if you could say a
few words about that episode.
It must have been interesting.
Thank you.
- Well, Columbia essentially
wanted to take over
Barnard College in the 1970s.
And there were very strong
Barnard trustees, women
who said, wait a minute.
We are not going to do that.
And they preserved the college,
which is thriving today,
I think, as a women's
college, in the context
of the larger university.
- So any conclusions from that?
- Look, its an
idiosyncratic case.
Barnard was different.
Barnard-Columbia was different
from Radcliffe-Harvard
because Barnard--
among other things, Barnard
had its own faculty.
When you don't have
a faculty, it's
a whole different
proposition as a college.
- Thank you.
- Hi.
I'm Susan [INAUDIBLE].
And I'm from the class
of '71 at Radcliffe.
So an observation
and a question.
I mean, I was aware--
I mean, I guess I
was just clueless.
But it never occurred
to me I wasn't
going to a coed institution.
I mean, I know that I had
been admitted to Radcliffe.
And we knew we were smarter
than the guys at Harvard
because there were 300
of us and 1,000 of them.
But beyond that and those dorms,
which I got out of as soon
as I could, it seemed to me--
I never would have
gone there if I hadn't
felt like it was a coed school.
So that was my experience.
Years later, I
thought, that's true.
There weren't many women
faculty, were there?
But my experience was as a coed.
We did every-- so all of
the stuff later on about
the merging and this and
that, it was sort of--
I don't know how
much that impacted
the undergraduate experience.
And then my question was to
you, it would be interesting--
I wondered-- you were
talking about the impetus
towards coeducation was purely
because the men's colleges were
losing some of
their best students
who didn't want to go
to all-male schools.
Wasn't that sort of-- wasn't
that also true for some
of the women's colleges,
the same kinds of debates,
that it wasn't because
they wanted to give up
women's-only education, but they
were not getting the students
they wanted to get?
So some of them went coed.
I don't know.
It would be interesting
to have a parallel--
- Yeah, that was--
- --talk about that.
- That was certainly the
imperative at Vassar.
Vassar, by the late 1960s,
was seeing a real drop-off
in applications and yields.
It was lagging well behind
Smith and Wellesley.
Vassar had the
problem of location.
Except for West Point a
half hour up the river,
there just weren't any
men's colleges nearby.
And getting a
significant population
of fully qualified
women students
was a pressing
concern for Vassar.
And in the case of
Vassar, the decision
was that the right
solution was to bring
men, which was a big relief
to alumnae after they
got to keep their campus.
They didn't have to
move to New Haven.
Sharing their campus
with men wasn't so bad.
At Smith and Wellesley,
that was an issue,
not because the
drop-off in talent
had been seen yet so much as
because of the fear of what
would happen with the
men's schools going coed.
Once you were competing
with Princeton and Yale,
for example, would a significant
population of talented women
keep applying to and
matriculating at places
like Smith and Wellesley?
And as at Vassar, could
you get enough talented men
if you decided on coeducation.
Smith and Wellesley both had
reasons for not going coed,
whereas Vassar had
reasons for going coed.
But the question of admissions
was front and center
for all of them.
- Great talk.
- Thank you.
- Hi.
I'm Connie Franklin.
I came to Radcliffe in 1968.
And I don't really
have a question so much
as a little testimonial,
because a million times as I
read your book and as I listened
to you today, I thought,
yes, yes, yes.
I remember that.
So an ode to the old Radcliffe.
It was a lovely time to be here.
It was like being in a small
school with the support
of gracious and interested women
in the form of the Radcliffe
administrators.
And yet you were in this
ocean of incredible resources.
And you did need their
support, because when
you walked into class, it
was a sea of male faces.
And they were not
always friendly.
In terms of the
relative qualifications
of the Cliffies as opposed
to the Harvard guys,
I had an epiphany that has
lasted with me my whole life
in expository
writing freshman year
when we peer reviewed
each other's papers
and I looked at what my male
counterparts had written.
And I thought, oh my god.
If this is the best of the
best, we are in deep trouble.
[LAUGHTER]
- That's it.
I remember walking
into Harvard Freshman
Union with a date
on a Friday night
and the tinkling of the
glasses, because a woman had
entered the room.
I remember an argument
with a guy at Harvard
who thought it would be
horrible if women came to live
in the Harvard Houses because--
and even if they came to
live in the Harvard houses,
don't let them into the
libraries in the Harvard
Houses.
It was quite a time.
And of course, at my
commencement in 1972,
a lot of us wore equal sign--
excuse me, the sign for
women with an equal inside.
And there was a
petition floating around
for sex-blind admissions.
Very controversial at the time.
Thank you for your work and
validating and showing it
all to us from a
different perspective.
Really.
- Thank you.
- Thanks so much.
That was wonderful.
My name is Genevieve Dempsey.
I'm a fellow at
the Hutchins Center
for African and
African-American research.
My question today is regarding
the classroom and discourse
in the classroom and how we
might bring some of the ideas
you talked about today
into the classroom,
regardless of whether it's a
physics class or world music
class, because oftentimes
I find that if I would like
to talk about gender, I have
to go to a class on gender
in Latin America or something.
And so I don't feel like--
I feel like your speech today
is a wonderful kind of testament
to how far we've come.
But I'm very much on
board with what you say.
I'm just wondering how do we
get this message to people
that are perhaps more
resistant to the ideas.
- I really understand
what you're
talking about in terms
of talking about gender.
When I used to teach big
lecture courses in 20th Century
American History, if I was
lecturing on the civil rights
movement, my male students
were fully engaged.
When I lectured on
the women's movement,
that was another matter.
Why are you spending our time
on this, was the reaction
that I would often get.
If I knew the answer
to your question,
I would be in the line of work
on transforming institutions
of higher education.
I think you have to be careful
to make sure not to always call
on male students.
I'm as guilty of this as anyone.
In my classes, you were greatly
relieved when the hands go up
rather than sitting
there thinking,
who is going to have
something to say to that.
And pausing to
think, wait a minute.
Those kids are all male,
or the last three comments
were from men, is sometimes
really hard to do.
So remembering to stop
yourself for a moment
and make sure that the
women are as fully engaged
in the conversation as the
men is the first thing,
I think, a faculty
member has to do.
And the second is making gender
a part of the conversation
when you're talking about
other topics, when you're not
in a course about
gender, but where--
American social history,
American political history,
where gender is part
of that conversation,
as race is inevitably
part of that conversation.
But the real solution,
you'll figure it out
as soon as I will.
- Hi.
I'm Ken [? Kaufman. ?] I'm
a member of the Harvard
class of '69.
I first wanted to thank you
for coming and speaking today
and also for your
book, which I've read,
which is really terrific.
I just wanted to
spend a minute or two
giving a Harvard student's
perspective on some
of the issues you
were talking about,
as somebody who was [INAUDIBLE]
involved in that at the time.
But Vietnam was going on and
a lot of other issues were.
I as a junior and
senior was involved
in one of the two Harvard
College student government
organizations, the
Harvard-Radcliffe policy
committee.
We were a little bit unusual
in that we had some Radcliffe
students and we had some
faculty members that we invited.
I became chair of the committee.
And Kay Tolbert, a Radcliffe
student, was the secretary.
And we traditionally did audits
of the undergraduate programs
of the major departments.
How good a job was
the English department
doing for undergraduates?
But some of us felt
pretty strongly
that while, as you were
saying, Harvard held itself out
as a coeducational institution,
it really was not in many ways,
particularly coming
as a freshman,
living in the yard, all
men, the Freshmen Union.
Dining facilities were all male.
The houses were all male.
And we felt that this was
indicative of a major cultural
issue at Harvard, which is that
female undergraduates didn't
have the same
educational opportunities
and were not viewed as
intellectual or social peers
or equals.
So we set up a subcommittee.
And we spent about six
months doing a major study,
taking polls and so on.
And we issued a
report, which I spent
a lot of time writing
over Christmas vacation,
'68, '69, in which the
committee had a lot of input on
and which we issued
in early 1969
saying that this was a
major issue, that it had
to be addressed,
that it was more
important than
many other issues,
and that for starters change
should come within the house
system.
And we recommended
a trial exchange
between three Harvard houses--
Lowell, Adams, and Winthrop--
and the three Radcliffe
houses as a first step,
the reason for that
being that those were the
three whose masters wanted
to have women in their houses.
There were many who did not.
And we recommended long
range that the houses
go coed, although
allowing potentially
for the option of
a non-coed house,
although nobody ended up
wanting that, and consideration
ultimately of a merger
between Harvard and Radcliffe
and also moving toward
gender-blind admissions,
increasing the number
of women admitted.
And we then started
politicking and met
with President Pusey in
mid-January, who basically said
he was in favor of
our main conclusions,
but he was skeptical that
Radcliffe would agree to them
because Radcliffe
valued its independence
and didn't want to be even
more under Harvard's thumb.
He also was concerned
about the legalities
with Harvard taking
on responsibility
for Radcliffe students.
We then met with
President Bunting
at Radcliffe, who
said she was in favor
of most of our recommendations
but Harvard would never
go for them, because
Harvard treated Radcliffe
as a kid sister and didn't
take it very seriously.
And it was then in February
that she invited two of us
to a Radcliffe trustees meeting.
They had never had
students there before.
And then, as you were
saying in your talk,
shortly after that the Radcliffe
governing board initiated
the discussions with Harvard.
And the Harvard faculty, after
a hiatus caused by the Vietnam
issues with SDS and
so on, ultimately
agreed with some of
our recommendations.
And the trial exchange
was initiated a year later
and the houses then went
coed, as you were saying.
And they started increasing
the numbers of women.
The only point I
wanted to make is
I think Harvard was an
example where student input--
and it came from
the Harvard side.
It was not from the
Radcliffe side--
really did play a role in
accelerating what probably
would have happened otherwise,
but in making it happen around
that time, and in shining
a light on these issues,
which, as you point out,
still persist to this day.
- You wrote a
really good report.
And it's a good
example of instances
where student initiative can
really make a difference.
And your examples at
Princeton as well, where
it isn't that the students
made something happen,
but made administrators
reckon with realities
that administrators really
just didn't see before.
- Well, thank you.
- Thank you.
- Did you ever get--
excuse me.
Meryl [? Sturbridge, ?]
class of '71.
This all resonates deeply.
Did you ever get a whiff that
when these men administrators
were talking about getting the
right kind of boys, that there
was a wrong kind of boy?
I know that there was
a lot of class change.
But was there any--
did you ever get any
whiff of homophobia?
- Nobody was talking about
homophobia, at least not
in any sources that I've seen.
The best boys were the
top-ranking boys, generally
at prep schools and some
of the best public schools.
That's what the best boys meant.
The all-around hugely
talented academically leaders
who were probably accomplished
on the playing field
as well as in student
government and had
the best grades, that's what
they meant by the best boys.
- Hello.
My name is Diane Williams.
And I'm a female alum of MIT.
And I went to school
when there was 14% women
at the undergraduate level
and when they used the Sharpie
to put W-O- men.
And we still had the urinals
in some of the [INAUDIBLE]..
So they didn't go fully coed.
I'm also an alumna of
Harvard, the Graduate School
of Education many years later.
And I'm curious.
I was here because
I saw the where
are we going, because I
know a lot of the history
certainly, having
lived some of it.
I personally am involved.
I'm the organizing lead
for an upcoming augmented
virtual reality hackathon we're
having at the MIT Media Lab.
And I'm specifically
part of diversity.
Women-- all the things in
tech that you mentioned.
I'm responsible
for ageism, sexism,
getting rid of any kind
of ism's, subject matter
expertise.
And that's sort
of my contribution
to the legacy of
four days, I get
to live the dream,
like what tech is not.
But I want to try to change it.
Is there anything else I can
do as a computer scientist
to try to encourage women to
pursue it in higher education?
Or stay with it in the field?
- It sounds to me
as though you're
doing a great job already.
I think establishing mentoring
initiatives with young students
who come into college,
who think they might
be interested in studying
computer science or math
or physics, and
having older students
or older women who have done
this essentially get together
with them and say, you should
do this, you can do this,
really makes a difference.
- OK.
Thank you.
- I'll make this quick.
I'm Susan [INAUDIBLE].
I have been president of the
MIT Women's Alumni Association
and vice president of the
MIT Alumni Association.
And maybe things have
changed radically
in the '70s when
women's [INAUDIBLE]
became very evident.
But starting in 1873,
MIT had been coed,
and it essentially was the first
coed school on the east coast.
And the women didn't
seem to have problems.
In fact, the research that I've
done on the women, many of them
actually earned not
only the same income
as men in the profession,
but actually earned more.
And speaking of Yale,
for one situation,
one woman who got
a medical degree
and worked in Europe,
when she came back
because her husband had died,
Yale actually went to her
and asked her to become
head of a new school,
to start a new school there
in a medical research thing.
So I think some
of the things that
might have happened in the
last part of the 20th Century
may not have been the same
that people faced earlier.
And in fact, like at Radcliffe--
not at Radcliffe.
I'm sorry.
Barnard.
Before Barnard was
established, women
could attend Columbia's classes.
And once Barnard
was established,
the women
undergraduates could not
attend Columbia classes,
only the graduate women.
So I think there a lot of
changes that occurred over
history that has to be
considered in the whole thing,
not only the west coast things
which you have pointed out.
That's all.
- Good for MIT.
I think we've done it.
Thank you all so much.
[APPLAUSE]